awaken for love but not your own
the life that you never thought you'd
know
coming
awaken for love but not your own a life
that you never thought
[Music]
foreign
people
like the right one
[Music]
foreign
the last time
[Music]
effect but not that much all right there
we go
hi everyone welcome everyone
today we are going to be hosting a Mario
Tennis tournament
playing some classic Mario Tennis for
n64. my name is Emma Fife I am a senior
video producer at fandom I'm Bailey
Myers I'm a writer and producer at
fandom and we are here on behalf of our
Collective fandom Gamespot Giant Bomb
brands
and we're very excited today to be
hosting a tennis tournament as a matter
of fact our very own uh Dan Reichert of
giant bomb went out to the people today
and found us uh
a bunch of members of the National City
youth Esports League who are going to be
competing against one another in this
Mario Tennis tournament some truly
selling competitors on the stage today I
am so excited
so for our first bracket we are going to
have Majid and Victor
hello
yep we're gonna have you have a seat
right here
all right so uh are you are you Majid
okay you're Majid you're Victor all
right Majid how are you today I'm good
you're good how are you feeling about
Mario Tennis I'm kind of nervous kind of
nervous okay who's your uh who's your
favorite character in Mario
um maybe
yeah
[Music]
Mario's a little one like the little Oh
Baby Mario yeah baby baby Mario okay and
what about you Victor
um my favorite character is Mario your
favorite characters Mario and are you
gonna play as Mario today yeah okay and
how are you feeling about Mario Tennis
kind of good because I I play a
different version of it you played a
different version of it oh this but
newer than not old
so yeah got it got it uh Rob can you
make come over and just make sure that
they're selecting everything correctly
here
all right
hold on just a second just can can you
just make sure they're playing the right
game mode yeah you're fine
all right here we go
all right one set two games playing on a
hard court
oh yeah oh and I gotta look at front
because that's where the game is yeah
right over there too yeah the game audio
is very loud competitors
all right first set
[Applause]
oh a really quick one very cool indeed
all right 15 love
oh you know the tennis words
15 15. all tied up get that instant
replay
oh powerful second hits
maybe Mario really coming in strong
showing up his old herself
it's a true battle of the ages Emma oh
nice volley wow
wow baby Mario good putting up a good
fight there
Baby Mario wins it nice nice nice nice
look another good volley today
do you think it's because Baby Mario is
so like little and live and oh all tied
up 15 yeah
older Marvel has a lot of other stuff on
his mind he has to focus on taxes yeah
his career I just kept saying I said
three different career things
all right okay
oh but he got it
all tied up
he did do a cool flip though and so he
might have missed the ball but he won
our hearts
[Applause]
[Music]
Mario staying in the game
this is gonna be a tight one folks it's
anyone's game at this point
oh my goodness
I'm learning now that I don't know
anything about tennis
how do the points work
yeah I have no idea
seems like they're just making up
numbers whoa
hey Mario
all right
[Music]
15 love adult Mario is really beating up
his own self
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah very good Hustle
[Music]
congratulations
Mario
fantastic work
yes Victor is our winner
[Applause]
[Music]
so Victor You're Gonna Go rejoin our
crew over in the chairs
and very well played majeed
congratulations extremely good game for
both of our competitors a spectacular
start to our Mario Kart tournament let's
bring up our next two contestants we've
got azerite and Sharma
[Applause]
hey you want to interview them yeah all
right
all right so what is your name
nice to meet you what is your favorite
character who are you gonna be playing
today Mario Wario I love it what's your
favorite thing about Wario
[Music]
yeah
and introduce yourself for the crowd I'm
sure well nice to meet you what's your
favorite character
Bowser what do you like about Bowser
I don't know he just that's fair he's a
cool big turtle what's not to like
oh it's gonna be a scoundrel off today
Emma character is here I'm hearing it's
going to be a match between Wario and
Bowser so it sounds like we've got a
couple of uh heels on our hands
I haven't experience
I'm expecting a uh I'm expecting a match
that's really lacking in Fair Play you
know sure sure
yeah I I want to see if Bowser does a
flip too yeah
I don't know
yeah I think the shell will get in the
way but I'd love to see it
all right here we go first service
Bowser oh vomited
though just missed it
the serve is still Bowsers
oh Dirty Love
why are y'all off to a slow start but I
believe that yeah he could turn this
game around okay yeah there we go oh
look at the power behind that in there a
very powerful backhand from Bowser for
sure
oh a game punch goes to Bowser here we
go
I gotta say it seems these two
Scoundrels are actually playing pretty
fair yeah all things considered yeah
they know it's best to keep the game
clean yes
[Music]
Mario approving that they can play by
the rules when it comes to tennis
ah
[Music]
oh it's all tied up tied up so excited
oh Bobby back there we go
nice return my Wario oh 15 15. this sure
is tennis
[Laughter]
oh oh my God
very good still in the game
change home all right
with the first serve and it goes right
back
good Hustle by Wario but he couldn't
quite get there oh
killer sir
oh oh
whoa right back there really good
oh
Mario hits the net I hear you're not
supposed to do that yeah
oh we're all tied up again time for a
tiebreaker
you can tell this is important because
the music's Fed Up yes all right we've
got Bowser with the advantage
oh
my God
look at them go
this is for all the marbles
all right all righty
oh
that's a really powerful serve for
Bowser oh yes exactly what you would
expect from Bowser being the side he's
very big and strong
and he's been playing Dennis his whole
life he's a proud
yes
good for power but not so much for
hustle yes but Warriors
stuff but he's also got some strength
there
okay
oh a good backhand it's all come down to
this
the tide River
in the game
this is intense
I am on the edge of my seat a couple of
evenly matched competitors
such a close one what um what an
incredible congratulations to you
azerite playing as Wario very good job
very good job is our winner
your seats and we are about to bring up
our next pair of competitors we have got
Jasmine and Kelly
all right
hello Jasmine hello Kelly
so who is your favorite Mario character
who are you thinking you're going to
play as today
I'm not sure you're not sure okay oh all
right
yeah pick whoever you like
and you're you're Jasmine and your Kelly
or did I get backwards Kelly Jasmine
yeah okay
great
Kelly do you have any idea who you're
going to be choosing today as your
competitor huh do you know who you're
gonna play as
yeah okay who do you think you're gonna
play as
you played it through I think oh
I would effect I love that excellent I
just love to watch a ghost play tennis
how does he hold the racket who knows
we love a ghost playing tennis we have a
ghost playing tennis now do you think
his uh lack of legs will affect his
hustle on the court I think it'll make
him I think it's gonna give him an
advantage yeah yeah
oh no and he's got some good celebratory
jumping because he can get that height
who is just flying quite literally
[Applause]
thrown off if I were playing against a
ghost on the other side oh absolutely it
would take a few seconds really come to
Crystal Clover happens to me still in
this game folks
[Music]
a good serve from Boo and a good return
from Mario
I do love that when Mario is not playing
he's the referee but when he is playing
blue Mario's the referee I think that
that's great it's very good
eight points
this is gay Point okay oh nice Mario
all right that's one for business went
to boo
all right here we go switching it up
oh
really really good sir really good way
to start
awesome
oh good backhand my boom
I just keep being impressed by the flips
even when they don't hit the ball I'm
like that's cool though I think that's
the thing we're missing in actual
professional tennis we need more
acrobatics
I'm gonna write yeah Mr tennis and I'm
gonna tell him I have an idea I think I
think we could get a rule change
all right all right Mario it's a chance
to win
it he died nice
all tied up
[Music]
I guess Mario ain't afraid of logos
[Applause]
[Music]
a really solid surf report
solid strategy to my
people yeah
it's really really
very good at survey
a surprising amount of power considering
that he has no actual match made of
ectoplasm yeah
look at that
[Applause]
oh a really good start for Mario going
back and forth trying to figure out what
way Mario's gonna take it and he just
quite oh yeah could return
[Applause]
no problem
[Music]
I think it's just very cute when boo
loses he squishes himself into the
ground I do the same thing so I find it
relatable
[Applause]
each point oh it is really tight
this is going to be a close game on the
way
all right all right
oh
wow
this is some really Spooktacular tennis
playing
[Laughter]
and yes I was sitting here the whole
time waiting to say that
like when's Gonna Be My Moment
we love a ghost bunny yeah he's a ghost
this is a closed game we've got all
right the tennis playing here happening
here this match is on fire oh wow look
oh Mario stays in it
all right Mario with the advantage I
every time I feel like I understand how
tennis scores something new happens or
I'm like I don't get this game at all
I'll explain it to you some other time
Mario
oh
[Applause]
they're coming in hot on the tiebreaker
[Music]
oh so close
first serve to Mario Bros volley in it
back and he's in that is three for boo
still for Mario
what competition here what competitors
first served us to boo Mario staying at
the game booth throwing it right back
really good volley there good hustle
I'm just saying Sports words now
oh
okay all right
[Music]
oh I didn't even see Boo get that oh
well we'll play it really close to the
line there
kind of hard to tell when he's not
standing there you know this could be a
match point hey
Mario put up a great fight there but I
think boo really fast
congratulations
you're going to be moving on in our
tournament you can go back over to join
your crew over there
and we are
going to bring in our next set of
players we have got Malachite and Chris
Chris
come on over YouTube let's talk about
Mario Tennis all right
let's take a seat special competitor
chairs yeah why don't you introduce
yourself to everyone
all right Chris what uh what character
are you going to be playing as today
malachite
what character are you going to be
playing Luigi Luigi oh oh brother it's a
battle of the brothers you love to see
it
all right
Luigi that's fine I love seeing Waluigi
now what is the relationship between
Waluigi and Luigi
that
that they are twin flames
[Laughter]
this is a mystery I've been trying to
solve for forever exactly who are Wario
Waluigi evil doppelgangers aliens wow
maybe they're just two cool dudes who
have similar things
either way this is superior good tenant
oh
oh nice Serve by one by Luigi but why
Luigi staying in the game oh nice
got good hustle because he has legs that
go for days but true Luigi is not gonna
be hit right now that while Luigi is
uniquely suited to be good at tennis yes
he's playing it close to the net
all right nice
oh well Luigi really say it right up in
front of the net and it just didn't pay
off this time
[Music]
oh I do like this strategy of getting
down close I think sometimes it makes it
hard to get to the other side quickly
but gosh you get that quick volley going
it can really take your competitors
[Applause]
okay
oh Lionel Richie is on fire and Luigi
just cannot quite keep up this is match
point
oh
with a really cool lightning move
[Music]
wow that was that was a quick one but it
was really impossible for both well done
wow congratulations
I mean that was crazy so uh that means
that Chris is moving on in our
tournament and today all right
that means our next match in our
semi-finals is going to be between
Victor and
azerite big round of applause
all right
laughs
okay
we're gonna get our game set up here
let's see if our competitors choose the
same character oh it looks like we went
Wario and Mario oh I love that so we we
just had a Waluigi and Luigi now we got
a Wario Mario nice symmetry
ask once we're told
oh Mario coming in
coming at first
[Applause]
wow Mario is on fire
where are you can't keep up
from what I understand
it right back on this second match
oh good though
all right a great serve and a great
return oh look at him go fantastic stuff
[Music]
tying it up
oh
15 15.
[Applause]
oh thinking about oh and it was
incredible
[Applause]
he always breaks it yep
we are hearing some extremely fun
friendly trash talking from our
competitors love it they're very in the
game very of the zone
oh
see Mario and Mario
all right this could be it
game point for Mario oh double fall
that's 15 to Mario wow they really don't
like when you hit the net
all right
let's see who is moving on to the finals
first goes to Mario I'm starting to
understand the game a little oh
yeah oh incredibly powerful returns very
good stuff
Wario struggling to clear the top of the
net with his serves but when he does my
goodness boy does he
oh it's time to cross the board
this is such a close match
[Applause]
warrior with the serve Mario ready to
set it right back
go everyone's playing my Wario
these are some very evenly most
competitors I am on the edge of my seat
here Emma
oh
warrior with a powerful backhand they're
really keeping Mario on his toes but
Mario
back
[Music]
[Laughter]
small fake out there
oh close
wow truly spectacular stuff here
oh Mario
that's fine
match point if Wario can win this he
takes it all will it be the scoundrel
today or everyone's favorite plumber
let's find out
wow
the advantage
if Mario gets this it's Mario
[Applause]
what a close match well done both of you
fantastic stuff
congratulations Victor is our winner
Victor is going to be moving on to the
final and that means that we have got
Kelly and Chris coming to the stage
yeah
all right
all right welcome back finals
Kelly and Chris choosing their
characters let's see if they go with the
same ones or we mix it up I mean Chris
was definitely killing it with uh
Waluigi it looks like we're sticking
with the same characters that we had
before love that we've got two Rascals
yep
I just I simply love both of these
characters so my heart is very torn here
oh nice I think I'll be happy if either
of them wins so that's great you
came with a matchup like this
[Applause]
we may have saved a screenshot as well
which is a little known technique in
tennis you don't see it that uh
look at boo getting in there oh the back
of the fourth on this is really
remarkable they sure are Tennessee
all right
oh good flavor really good stuff
you really see no one's holding anything
back here in the semi-finals who takes
the game this is the exact kind of
gameplay that we would expect to see
this level of skill in our excitement
absolutely absolutely
truly riveting folks
[Music]
a point
foreign
play and sometimes
you can't reach doesn't pay off payoff
so true
and it's best to just play it really
really good serve
30 all
okay this is a close game everyone
[Music]
gotta say it is a little stressful
having all of the box back there it
seems like if you hit one with the
tennis ball it could be pretty bad
it could be pretty bad yeah I would put
them there if it were me personally but
I'm not in charge of the Mario Tennis no
[Applause]
Dirty Love waluigine
oh there we go we're connecting with
that powerful very good oh pretty good
strategy the last time that Waluigi came
to play yeah
this could be it
incredible gameplay
Waluigi in the Battle of all licks
versus no legs
across the winner moving on Chris you
don't have to go anywhere you can just
stay right there congratulations Kelly
on a game very well played all right
let's bring back Victor
all right we're gonna go back
two players there we go all right
who is gonna be playing today it is
Waluigi versus yep
hang on
all right for our final match we are
going to do one set six games
this is for all the marbles people of
San Diego who will be the winner who
will take home
everyone gets a prize but who will take
over the winner prize
[Music]
that's served by Mario but Waluigi ready
to send it right back just can't quite
get there in time this is
Sparkle like diamonds when he gets the
point is it nice seeing that right uh
waluigi's High Sparkle yeah yeah that
sounds right
it's that dastardly twinkle yeah oh he's
just got a charge too
[Music]
oh yeah no see having the bums back
there is not a good idea
yeah and that's the advantage to Mario
if Mario can get this that is the game
and Mario takes it incredible start
oh
the focus on our competitors faces
oh Mario trying to do a big play there
but it just didn't quite pay out
30 love waluigine
thank you
oh I didn't quite make it a time close
on that one seems like this side of the
Court's really working for Waluigi
all right we're all tied up
get in this game with that first serve
here second serve
now we've seen Victor used this approach
before the fake out sir yes yes really
clever the kind of move you'd expect
from a Waluigi so when Mario does it it
really takes you by surprise Waluigi not
faltering oh
oh yeah
30 all
is he gonna do with this time is he
gonna go this time no
[Laughter]
this is how you play with your opponent
psychologically yeah yeah really really
messing with his Minds with our minds I
keep thinking this is gonna be the time
yep never is
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
a hilarious strategy that did not quite
pay off but was funny nonetheless
I'm gonna try it again though he's
trying it again
oh nice nice
oh Luigi
stay ready
Wario not quite clearing the top of the
net oh that's 15 to Mario
thank you
Mario's favor
oh oh
waluigi's staying in it Mario going for
a forehand but he should have gone
backhand
oh nice backhand by Mario
oh
Waluigi going for the big play
[Music]
oh
Mario time
[Music]
still anyone's game here today folks in
our thrilling Mario Tennis tournament
final
between Victor who's playing Mario and
Chris at Waluigi
both Fierce competitors wow
with unprecedented levels of skill and
hustle
this one really is a nail biter they are
showing us how this game is meant to be
played a truly remarkable play
Mario with a big Advantage here this
could be it for this match
[Music]
and Waluigi is still in the game
tomorrow
three two
laughs
ah
Waluigi taking a lead here Waluigi does
seem to do really well on this side yeah
game point for Waluigi
[Applause]
Mario with the first serve
and 15 love
oh 30 love
these competitors are so evenly matched
we've been going back and forth trading
victories
[Music]
it really could be anyone's game here
and uh that's what I love yeah
look this is the final we were expecting
to see some good competition and we are
oh wow all tied up 30 30.
ha ha
good play by Waluigi
this is game point for Waluigi and there
it is he takes it
[Applause]
all right
really good sir
oh
Waluigi really coming in hot here I feel
like he's hit his stride he's like
figured out his Groove and he's not
letting what Mario psych him out with
the foe starts
really impressive stuff for both of them
and Mario's still in it
oh
the game
[Music]
incredible volley look at them
Wednesday
first to Mario
's making a comeback he's not gonna be
taking down that easily no
Mario is the hero after all the title
characters he's not going down without a
fight yes
[Music]
foreign
match point for Waluigi here
[Applause]
all zero folks
is our champion congratulations
fantastically well played oops Yeah it's
very well played to all of our
competitors today let's have a big round
of applause for all of our players
great job everybody what amazing
sportsmanship truly incredible exactly
how the game is meant to be played yeah
fantastic job by all today that last
match between Chris and Victor was a
real nail fighter
serious tennis skills absolutely I feel
like I learned a lot about tennis today
uh I learned you're not supposed to put
bombs behind where the balls go it's bad
yeah I mean that's uh I don't think
you're gonna find that at Wimbledon or
anything no no no no no yeah but with
Mario anything goes thank you so much
everybody for joining us for our Mario
64 tennis tournament uh don't go
anywhere we will be right back very
shortly with a cozy gaming hour
featuring the likes of heevo and Super
Mario 3D World so if you want to just
have a a nice chill time here on this
Saturday afternoon this is the place to
be thank you so much dream thanks
everybody
daily
[Music]
something wait
ing
[Music]
foreign
I can see your story
[Music]
again
oh yeah looks like we got everybody oh
yeah all right
someone needs to hit a foreign
oh I guess I'm one player what game are
we playing
uh we're playing hivo oh I've never
played this I actually haven't played it
either
all right hey welcome to Cozy gaming
yeah
we're gonna hang out play some games uh
we said it'd be cozy the games we're
doing are actually kind of Cooperative
we need to rely on each other it's not
gonna be so cozy by the end I don't
think no I don't know if that's a good
idea
costume oh damn oh yeah
meatballs
all right I think I know who I want I'm
gonna be the uh
that's the way to do it
yeah
I'd have spaghetti arms oh look at that
mustache that's it oh yeah
thank you so much I'm gonna be I'm just
gonna be spaghetti
yeah I like that so right analog doesn't
do much does it all right oh no I lost
my SpaghettiOs
across gas things like that we're gonna
get the spaghetti to its goal yeah like
yarn or something a bone spaghetti all
right yeah like Mama used to make yeah
the crunchy the good crunchy spaghetti
yes
all right so you use the stick to move
your arms okay and then you can grab
with these it's your little mythical for
me all right everybody I'll use the
shoulder buttons to grab oh okay
[Music]
see that you're gonna be like a little
spider oh I see
oh no
oh
okay okay
wait wait I'm clearly not getting it
Emma where are you I'm right here Emma
come on I don't know come on wait what
do I do hold your hold your paper grab
with one arm okay grab with like one arm
and now now I'll go down
[Music]
there you go
over time
[Music]
we could have grabbed you because I
think we didn't just let you fall we
were just hanging out that seemed like
the right choice to me though she has to
learn the hard way exactly you're right
oh no okay y'all this is all about like
with
[Music]
I'm so sorry that I have just this this
conceptually is not working for me I
think you're just rolling off should we
go get her yeah can somebody oh yeah are
we okay all right there you go bring the
right hand into there before you let go
whatever
sorry I didn't know you could use the
ball very conservative and everybody
that's a world record that's a world
record the world record of the absolute
worst possible time
all right now oh my gosh
does anyone want to grab my hand yeah I
would love to give me my your hand all
right
I'm pulling you up as much as I can well
then I gotta go this way
[Music]
here we go okay come on I'm trying oh
we might we might be different
characters we might be different
characters now all right there we go uh
I don't know why I became them okay
skeleton guy now all right yeah what is
going on
is figuring out which character you are
thank you
let me do it spaghetti bones all right
okay let's try all right
okay I think I'm in okay I should I
should be spaghetti bones again which is
very exciting for me all right I think
I'm okay I'm
this guy okay okay I see who I am are
you just gonna hold me you're gonna drag
me down all right let's do it all right
you're you're literally smashing my face
in the ground right now and I can't I'm
sorry okay
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go underneath
that's 20 to life
someone else
[Music]
right now
all right
[Music]
flinging my boat
okay oh I know it's because I'm upside
down okay okay okay okay all right all
right I can do this all right on my own
I don't believe anything of rap people
come on yeah you got this all right all
right swinging Emma to you take her okay
all right let go of your right hand
bones take my hand oh no yes all right
now we're a big pile this seems like a
really bad don't worry it's good no this
is fine this all right hand bones do not
let go right okay okay pile here you go
spaghetti spaghetti
let's go okay
okay no no no I freaked out
yay oh David I don't know you didn't
make it okay okay okay okay okay I'm
good no no no no no spaghetti there
that's all that matters
okay rolling around in my little bowl
all by myself yep okay
yeah decision
all right hang on I'm coming okay
[Music]
oh no I fell okay hang on I'm coming
back I'm coming back
all right okay laying in my bowl left
hand let's get left hand fan up there
yep yep get some momentum all right now
let go left hand okay oh oh I let go of
you okay I got it just throw it over
there we go I think the goal now is just
to have it so Emma doesn't do anything
and we just throw over here we're gonna
switch that left hand let's go
I got it I got left hand ready ah I want
to grab one more time
oh
oh okay okay okay okay
I am not helping I'm letting you staying
in my bowl I can't get to you all right
you're going back to her house
it's about friends helping friends now
spaghetti oh gosh
all right here we go I'm back I'm back
here you go I got it okay you got me
okay
all right thank you
yeah okay
grab me yay all right
thank you this is our journey yeah let's
go with the right hand over there okay
yeah
yeah okay okay hang on
okay
there you go oh okay you're good all
right let's go with the L but not oh
yeah never mind never mind yep hang on
do not go do not let go bar yeah there
you go right now all right
all right
[Music]
that was slick slick
snaps a pile of crunchy
bones
I've killed a man uh you got it man you
can do it
there it is nice you gotta look at stuff
yeah strong grip muscles yeah
you know I work out don't worry about it
all right come join us
and it's a world record
[Applause]
yeah fastest time ever for sure
all right I'm feeling better about this
now oh yeah wait this this one looks
easier we got this we have to just get
around
outside goodbye I'm going over the side
yep yep you got it okay
oh
yeah I feel like we can't help each
other as much with this one though we
don't really I don't know if we even two
really we've got this
come on self there we go I'm gonna beat
you grub I got this almost
that's not fair you have crappy on your
side yep
I Can't Get Enough momentum to get my
arm there we go there is that much
inside of you yes I'm I'm very juicy
yeah yeah I go all right
so if I have a balloon can I still do
what I want okay go ahead I can move
around oh my balloon's gone oh okay
[Applause]
okay I let go right yeah I did let go
okay hang on let me stop in there I look
at our R there we go I want a real thing
got it nope nope it's okay we got it all
right there oh come on oh yeah okay
that's crazy
got it okay we're good you only have to
like worry a little bit let me decide
there
actually for some reason okay all right
I got it
working smart oh no I'm upside down
there we go come on
come on okay got it yeah nice yes yeah
to the Bowl all right you let go
no no
oh my god
well done we are really improving here
we go just because it took me a little
while to conceptually understand this
game I was like don't get it now
single player while we you guys are
playing multiplayer bye
see you later
where am I all right let's give you a
little bit of a jump work together okay
okay someone okay someone grabbed the
ground to the left
here we're all gonna like use them
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh that's amazing okay
oh we just missed it all right here we
go okay okay here we go here we go okay
grab my hand grab my hand I got you you
go take my hand
every now and then wait right yeah but
it's gonna be okay all right I'm like
okay
another wall and then now let go of me
okay all right all right now don't let
go okay here we go
all right okay grab it with r at the
very bottom just roll out the grass okay
okay
all right all right really really good
time
never let go here we go all right I'm
holding here we go
okay
okay all right now we gotta get bones
you gotta get me gotta get Emma of
spaghetti let go with L yep and then we
can grab it actually there you go
nice okay hold on bad about the fact
we're in the position okay okay yeah but
it's fine I'm not gonna let go this time
[Music]
nice okay
it was pretty close
all right all right all right
I'm just gonna hang out here bye guys
all right Bailey I'm sorry oh it's okay
it's okay it's okay I'm gonna come grab
your hand okay I'll catch you I've got
your arm yeah you can let go of my arm
there you go oh no okay okay climb it
right all right all right here we go
whoa acrobatics
all right you got the semi I believe in
you I'm mainly like I'm doing L squeeze
let go Bailey
all right here we go
all right I'll come down I'm coming down
maybe I can't get myself to roll down
[Music]
all right all right spaghetti let go R
yep all right here we go
right now let's get some momentum do a
swing
all right all right all right all right
let's go all right that's good Bailey
you got it okay okay great we got he's
got our omelet go of R okay okay I'm
gonna all right yep go a little bit
earlier but we don't talk about that got
it all right I'm gonna go R and wait for
this thing to stop and then I'm just
gonna drop this off and just drop us all
[Applause]
thank you
not considered inside right now I think
I think the the pirate is inside the
bowl wait hold on is does pirate
technically not get it get in there here
we go there we go all right this next
level I'm gonna introduce you to a new
mechanic once we get there okay but we
barely see this one this one's very
important though
all right
whoa oh wow
oh
all right okay take my hand I got you
spaghetti let go of r
I'll grab that thing the coin see what
it does I'm gonna try
I'm very stuck all right so got it if
you hit a face button okay thanks if you
hit B you can toot and this does give
you a little bit extra no it gives you
extra moral support
what does it do I got a coin
and now
oh thank you a bodily sounds all right
hold on hold on hold on grab the coin I
don't know what it's for but grab it
okay
I got it nice
okay what do I have
remember spaghetti and meatballs gets
here
oh
with this bad boy right here
even four
oh
should we eat that or is that just for
fun I think it's for fun I don't know
all right uh I'm gonna let someone there
we go yeah there we go all right okay
all right grab it no
did I toot you off you farted
okay listen that actually is that what
that does yes oh no
all right
[Laughter]
it's funny
stop farting I can't help it my beans
left right I'm sorry okay
pirate Lego of L I've got us with r we
can get more links Bailey's not crazy
yeah you climb us there you go that's
like a ladder yes all right now
stop
all right we gotta go rescue our we
gotta rescue our teammate all right
let's go I'm in the bowl okay okay okay
all right
how do I oh okay I typed it okay you
could hop onto that and then what okay I
can make it over with that yeah
keep pulling it you don't you guys don't
have to leave I'll figure it out all
right
you got it oh oh yeah oh that works that
works all right all right I'm good let's
just go across all right show me Lego me
GA bikes
the violence in this game
all right yeah just someone just die
that would have been
shooting me today
not great yeah
bye
okay I'm grabbing you I'm throwing you
off
okay
the coin's got to be for some I'm gonna
let go it's like a bonus if you get it
in the slot I've got the koi all right
then I'm gonna go to the end so let go
of my all right hang on okay
I'm double hanging nobody right now
holding the coin okay oh my God can we
ride on this
all right can we ride
nope that would be enough I was driving
all right let's go let go of L first all
right hang on huh all right oh hang on
somebody come grab us
hey okay that worked oh you got me okay
great oh no oh
I got thrown what is that gaseous I
don't know I don't like it the Llama
farted this looks like a really bad
thing I got the coin again
in this game
come to my right hand grab us grab us
okay roll down I'm Gonna Roll down and
you're gonna catch me right
well you could catch her
ah no oh I see with the freaking stink
Cloud that's happening here okay
all right I don't think you can assume
it's a stink hang on hand yeah that's
pretty rude it looks stinky well okay
all right now I can see that's just what
clean gas it looks like yeah all right
come on all right bones you climb down
okay I'm over here waiting with my right
hand take the hand there we go okay okay
all right now I'm in it
oh my God this is you want to get get on
the end of that coin that right hand
grab it grab the one with the right
Daddy go down to uh Emma yeah uh let go
like put the mud the coin yeah drop the
point all right it's gone what I mean
yeah let go
of yeah oh okay okay is the one who has
to go down further I have to go down
further okay do I need to drop L just
let go Ellen press it again right away
okay
somebody else is holding me it's fine
right right so we just got to get you to
agree I know I'm trying I'm right here
all right here we go this is it uh
hang on let me try something
oh get that arm out here it's right
there
ah right there
okay there we go okay I got this
okay
all right
yep there you go okay let go let go okay
now we gotta get Emma's yeah
I know hang on like a pendulum I'm like
upside down I don't know it looks like
I'm melting I'm basically dead I can't
get myself by farting
no no
wait I can't even see myself
okay here I am
somebody grabbed me trying to
okay you guys got me yeah I don't think
so no okay
yeah we gotta change tactics here oh
yeah okay just climbed down
I'm Letting Go Bye uh-oh you start at
the top grab okay
all right crap
okay all right that's fine but you're
right yep there we go I'm grabbing
someone else okay and come get me
yep there you go grab me all right I got
you you can all right yeah let's go here
we go we got it all right okay all right
can you guys be longer
Bailey needs to let go
and come down to me all right so okay
stop holding my spaghetti butt yeah
that was it
let go of your arms pirate I'm trying
you guys could be a little bit longer
oh I know
pirate if you let go of my spaghetti but
we can be fine I'll let go of the
spaghetti butt thank you oh there we go
see I grabbed you all right I love
spaghetti I can't help myself sometimes
all right okay okay yeah you guys got to
be longer yeah so whoever's red like oh
yeah that's it why he's grabbing me I
can't like you have to let go of me and
go no
gotta Trust all right there we go there
we go there we go there we go
here we go
okay
yeah okay careful careful go swing all
the way up
okay I'm gonna go grab this thing okay
all right should I let go Bailey all
right grab the bottom of this of this
corner here okay right here there you go
okay
oh
my god oh hey you all made it pull that
anyways wow that was almost like it was
deliberate
okay
all right everybody get in I'm trying so
hard too
there we go oh [__] okay all right
thank you
[Music]
all right all right I might have farted
a little bit yeah
oh it's part of the game clearly you're
supposed to
oh my God
hold on hold on
yeah
you're doing it
okay Bailey we got this oh it's all gone
wrong oh man
all right hold on
okay
hold on okay
okay all right hang on the fury in my
heart okay what what Fury I think that
was just the ball that was just good
clean fun I can't move
oh man that's why I can't move yeah who
knows who's gonna be
gonna be I'm still spaghettibo who am I
I am still this guy this is great pirate
oh wait yeah I am no okay we gotta
[__] one more time okay
this is going great oh that Nintendo
seal equality I want it on the record
that I was trying to get in the bowl no
you are yeah
okay
okay uh I think I'm still the same okay
no okay we're all back in the beginning
let go of our spaghetti
all right that's me okay okay this is
gonna work this is totally gonna work
fart now
I am actually astounded that that works
yes that's right another world record
that was shocking
oh boy
all right Sue now
I'm I'm Skelly boy
whoa who is that what's going on
okay bye bones
Bailey let go of R yep there you go
yep yep there you go there you go okay
yep
okay okay
I'm gonna try to swing to the left let's
go right yep yep yep here we go
it's okay
okay
I'm trying to grab you and not the wall
uh okay okay I'm gonna put my hand down
you grab my hands there we go now you
let go of the wall
no she's got the wall too now I'm on the
wall okay great we're good all right
someone uh spaghetti's guy here we go
okay all right hold on let's do a swing
we'll go up to the birdie no one grab
anything yet yeah no no almost we're
getting there we're getting there we
might not be quite quite close enough
a little bit of blood all right we got
this I think this is working
yep
oops I just rolled straight off I
thought someone had me
oh yep okay oh hi that's okay
iris is going by himself
got this
okay
I'm going pirate wow that's a lot of
death
okay okay
we are mixed up here oh no okay okay
okay hang on where does the pirate can
let go hang on I got this pirate like oh
I got your arm you got my God okay I got
you are you sure yeah just gonna keep
dying okay okay there we go get over
here get a balloon
if you get over here we can swing our
asses into the bowl
I got it
okay all right you can use momentum to
throw yourself up here come into our
blob oh my God I'm trying to become one
with your blob now join us
yeah I think just swing a little bit all
right
Yep this is perfect like let go let go
let go okay all right ready here I'm
gonna let go I'm not ready
it's like we practice
all right I'm gonna let go of oh
into the bowl all right that's fine
oh I can't grab the wall hang on you can
grab the wall from there you're good
yeah I got it I got it I got it
I'm not farting hey
[Laughter]
foreign
all right
oh well we're like a little totem pole
now
I miss those days I missed the totem
pole days of my life
okay all right okay yes where am I who
am I a tough one all right
all right we're gonna have to climb each
other we're going to like swing but yep
all right I'll grab pirate yep I got it
okay I have us attached with me
and then we're gonna go up oh I gotta
get a little bit longer yeah
the ground is so swing all the way to
the ground and I can crawl there we go
oh okay that's good okay oh that's slap
sound all right yep okay that was the
sound of like this
Let It Go
oh it's me actually is it no there we go
yeah okay
oh yeah good okay
all right
yeah that worked great okay let it go
okay hold on we got this
all right grab it yep got it good job
all right all right
attached to the bowl
I might have let go
I was betrayed I just thought we all had
it oh oh oh
okay hang on all right Bailey okay all
right we can go we'll get the next one
you're holding you're you're gonna get
the balloons yeah I'll pre-fort the bowl
for you thanks thank you please stop
offering to do that
I'm holding it
oh you just gotta see
aim it up all right all right up up up
there we go there we go there we go this
works oh no no no no no there we go
I'm in the bowl
not have enough farts in it okay I'm
being held okay there we go
swing yourselves into the bowl I'm
trying
I'm taking my righty out here for you
I'm waiting for you I'm good I'm trying
to get it there we go okay here we are
there we go I will not use your help
we're in the Bowl yay
I don't know about this whole thing I
don't know if this is a celebration that
I want to be a part of oh fart bull fart
bull
okay
there we go
[Music]
that happened I didn't even let go cool
okay bye forever
I got Emma's always like someone give me
a hand please and we're just off doing
our look I'm I'm playing the game the
right way yeah
you have farted zero people to death so
you're doing great in my book okay I got
it okay
Spirit yeah you're good sorry I was just
keep it true all right spaghetti oh my
God I was not holding oh okay okay hang
on see this is this I just don't trust
hold on I'm gonna get this guy actually
Mr Bones good
there we go
oh not yet I'm holding I'm holding it's
okay swing
ah let go it like I bounce off of it
okay
oh it won't let me grab it here we're
done let's go let's get a bit more a
little bit more midtone okay we are nice
noise all right let go and pop all right
oh okay hang on you're holding on to me
yep all right cool I'm holding a pirate
butt
Let It Go
okay
oh
wow
it's okay they sent us here at least it
started us here yeah all right I don't
remember doing anything the trail at the
highest level I just could not help oh
we just got tweeted on by a bird
take my hand I got it
all right you really didn't think a fart
would be that powerful all right we're
good
powerful fight we're good and then
spaghetti decided to do something on
their own
I am okay I got it to all of you we
could go up and over climbing up in
there there you go
okay great letting go of left all right
all right there we go under it doesn't
matter yeah I think under is probably a
little easier
for the needle and there we go there we
go got it okay all right I'm gonna go
I'm not holding on anything oh yeah like
when you're in the middle you don't
really do much yes okay we're gonna have
to moment of this oh no
[Laughter]
Okay so
right oh no okay I fell but it's fine
they'll drop it excellent
couldn't have gone better oh I didn't
realize spikes okay okay I got the
Edge I think
do I
get off of me
all right I'm trying are you holding me
okay holding something okay there we go
oh boy okay
all right
okay we got it
oh it's right okay got it everything's
gonna be okay
all right great
all right okay
oh
oh my hey a little unusual but I think
we can I'll try to treat you in there
now
don't all right ready yep got it
[Music]
yep let go of that there you go okay
okay whoa too much okay okay
[Music]
thank you
oh
who's tooting that's irresponsible
yeah
one more run
I think these are gonna be the pro
levels this is what we are it's what
we've been building towards oh God we're
already going okay interesting
all right I feel like we're kind of on
our own every everywhere for themselves
all right okay
oh wait no it's all dark and spooky here
I need you guys
actually maybe we go to the top and grab
it is that a cloud or something to grab
okay okay let go of my face
foreign
spaghetti I hate you all right
there we are teamwork yeah you got this
no
that's what you get for not doing the
teamwork thing
I wanted to be first come join our chain
oh there's the bowl
I'm in the pool Wait no that's not me
because I thought it was me let go of me
all right hang on let me go get the
balloon
oh grub it takes so long
all right it's not that hard
what's the go but okay okay hang on
I can't go I'm stuck I'm trying to climb
around and pull the thing for the
balloon
you're over here having a fart party
without you there we go
oh
[Music]
oh look at my faces
oh boy
hi guys how's the pile going okay
all right I feel like we're just stuck
okay I'm gonna go this here we go all
right
okay
gotcha
I'm already in oh there it is there we
go I'm going to pretend that cheerings
for the Evo all right let me go there we
are nice okay
oh no oh no oh no okay okay wait oh
there's a spiky spider okay we need to
have it happen is the skeleton yep just
climb across or something or no wait
wait I'm being held okay I think I think
skeleton and spaghetti just have to like
own us two people okay too many people
all right I'll let go of our spaghetti
and meatball okay all right all right
we're gonna make it with this jump all
right
number nine yep all right here we go oh
God there's another one bones let's go
all right you want me to let go
okay bones let go okay
all right here we go we got this you
would be spaghetti against the world
spaghetti all right we probably won't be
able to do this we're going to start
over okay
[Music]
we're in the bowl yeah I got it all
right
you can do it
it's almost hard
that was hilarious I literally cannot
see
here we go all right you got me uh yeah
and I hold on hold on okay
[Music]
thread that needle there we go all right
don't let go yeah there's another Spike
up top this is a heads up all right
you might want to just grab the wall
instead yeah yeah grab the wall
and I'll let go of the balloon okay yeah
there we go
okay uh
yeah I guess you let go there we go yeah
all right let go of the blue
okay all right Dave get back in the bowl
all right
what the hell
is that heaven it might be I wonder if
that's light or something I'm gonna die
and check it out it's the heavy side
like oh yeah now you got now you've got
your right hand You're Gonna Go your
left hand now you're okay yeah yeah
that's dropper
yeah David the bowl Dave in the bowl
oh yay
[Applause]
we love to see it oh no yay
oh oh with some Lots okay
who needs to lock things not me okay
this is uh scary okay hang on hang on I
have an idea
[Music]
yeah okay okay yeah
all right we're like uh we're just a
chunk
yep
there we go nice okay okay you know what
put you back over here bye bye
all right you guys go okay
it's fine
oh my God look at this okay
that's a thing
yep somebody grabbed me
trying to I got your butt yeah you got
me you got my butt yeah your whole butt
yeah
this Wall's in the way swing me up
can't really do that no I guess not
guys
what what I didn't do anything
wait we're not
wait we are
not
I'm sending a balloon it's not gonna
help that much though
okay really it's not gonna help that
much all right all right all right there
I am
okay I'm leaving I am hoeing go back
you got it it's to give you the exact
wrong way
no [__]
oh shoot wait and I die oh wow whatever
yeah what are you doing over here I fell
again you guys
oh no yeah all right that one coming
okay all right all right serious time
okay
[Music]
stop it you're pulling me back you're
holding me down
all right
all right I don't even know which is my
left and which is
left left okay
there we go
okay
[Music]
while this is very nice and all we don't
want to work together in the middle
okay
here we go
there we go okay guys
oh very nice okay got it okay lingo yep
all right I'm gonna look on my left yeah
so you have to do solo for that part
yeah we were dragged no
all right
let go of me you're not you can't I
can't take you with me I can't take you
with me hang on no no darn it
okay yeah you got this Bailey there you
go you got it what my spaghetti Bunny's
too big
man
all right so you gotta have your hand up
a little bit okay okay I understand now
whoa all right
play spaghetti body
strategic farts
okay great
fine
okay I Believe In You Pirates I believe
in you
okay well I died holding the coin
so it's all worth it
right
and left oh come on
all right
all right I think you have to hold off
the whole time so you can avoid the
spike while you're going over that part
you got this you got this yes yes yes oh
my God hold up just hold up you got it
okay
yep
I'm glad yep
all right so for this part you have to
swing and let go once you get to the top
okay well I can also help people
uh you might swing them into the spike
though
I don't know I meant like to swing
people over uh yeah
okay I guess I'll let go do that okay
what is it
is it gonna be another unicorn that
farts everywhere grab it I'm trying I
was trying to but all right
hey
everybody's here do we all have to grab
it or something all right never mind yay
[Applause]
see now it wants us
oh hey
[Music]
I think a lot of these levels have
become more like solo levels
all right I'm gonna let go of my left
yeah Bailey I think we're together
trying yep there you go there we go
all right okay
okay excellent okay you're left okay
hold on woo
feel like I'm racing around right now
how do I do this
okay uh yeah this is a little awkward
hang on hang on I think we go back
together well that works there we go
swing you around like this I guess we're
gonna yep yep yep whoops yeah we're
gonna need help all right I got it
okay
hey maybe the balloon will be helpful
okay that works all right there you go
balloon I'm still in I'm still in enjoy
a balloon dig it
all right
oh I can't I cannot take it that way
this is not how old all right it's fine
I died again okay this is okay this is
all good oh I died again
nope uh I like how the balloon goes into
one thing this is the first spot
possible
oh no I'm stuck okay
all right okay
okay I'm doing it the balloon is not
helpful in this one like at all
get out of here it's not my space yeah
get out of here yeah
oh I had it and I let it go and I let it
go somebody
reach all right let's help them yep
[Music]
over here get out
oh my God
okay all right Bailey you go
okay I am yup you got it yep use my body
that's great
all right
oh my God I'm trying not to park so bad
here we go
in real life
all right
oh boy oh God yeah you got it you got it
excellent
all right come on Spaghetti
come on spaghetti I can't get in the
bowl no really no oh my God
[Music]
get the
you guys got one of yours has to let go
yeah there you go
there you go let's go okay give me the
bowl
[Music]
[Applause]
that wasn't bad at all
except for that part when I died five
times in a row well yeah that was
actually suppressive not great not great
work all right oh okay
this feels like a grab on right away yep
oh no I said it and then I immediately
fell to my desk
I think it's a pretty similar one where
we're just like working on the road
where am I moving level oh my God
yeah I need you guys to get higher
please
we're going up where do I go I can't see
anything
foreign
it's okay let go yep there you go
grab what do we grab I have no idea
we're grabbing something
okay ham all right
the darkness is closing in
I don't think it actually is I think the
camera's just moving up but it feels
very ominous
whoa
come on buddy let's go
[Music]
yeah
whoa no oh no hey hey that actually
worked out all right yeah
it's like damage boosting
strategic death I love it strategic yeah
damage boosting
you had speed Runner strats that's right
yes
we're going for hivo time
you can't quite get it okay left
whatever
God oh no why would I
would oh your blood guy oh yeah first
thing I'm doing the same thing
boost me up
let's fall off right now it'll actually
boost you really yeah sick okay we'll
damage boost
yeah okay baby
oh boy
all right go for it
yep
okay Bailey
yeah all right I'm not holding on to
anything so all right all right
I can't move
okay
all right now if you guys die again yeah
up here yeah that's it that's it there
we go
yay goodbye bones no
oh that's fine
hey what's up oh
no
what I didn't even let go I'm just gonna
damage boost my way um through this
there you go I'm on the wall I'm getting
it
ready and hanging out here I am so soon
uh yep
oh shoot oh hey
you want the balloon
there you go balloon balloon no no
[Applause]
all right pirate okay oh no no left
right
balloon good job
I'm dead somewhere down there I was
trying to get to them oh cool now if you
damaged everybody up here
Okay
who wants a balloon all right all right
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
there you go okay hopefully I won't ride
the balloon to my death this time
okay balloon
let's go all right yeah well then you
just take it under and around
or over and around
follow your heart
let's go all right let's go
[Applause]
all right all right what time were we
done here I don't even know I haven't
looked at a clock one more one more
three
if I know what button does what oh wait
no there we go
there we go
all right
last chance to prove ourselves all right
I'm gonna I don't believe in US
[Music]
okay this is another teamwork one
and I'm really worried okay okay I'm
ready all right
okay someone grab me okay let go
spaghetti spaghetti let go okay there we
go all right let me roll down ah someone
grab spaghetti all right crappy I'm
spaghetti I know I got you okay all
right oh so no one was grabbing me
crappy I'm spaghetti I guess we're all
going yay
yay oh good all right we lost all right
wait hang on don't grab me yet yeah we
definitely okay he's a pirate all right
hang on I think I got you oh no now you
got me okay all right here we go now
we're gonna swing you together
nice
all right
[Applause]
okay a little too much
[Music]
dumb man okay
oh no
we were both trying to be the beginning
okay okay
we were doing so good okay
we've got a little bit backwards at
skill I think okay it's all in the party
I got you okay
this is the big one
yeah all right I think I need to let go
of L I think yep sure okay
uh-huh okay I got it all right here we
go
our little triangles oh you got it all
right let's go just a little bit of oh
not yet
[Music]
oh
boy's good all right here we go here we
go
my friends They're All Dead okay we got
this
damn
[Music]
oh
blue yes oh my God
abruptly we have spaghetti okay let's go
all right
you can swing yourself into the bowl and
do a spaghetti
okay we got this no yeah
[Music]
all right let go you're good we got I
got you okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right all right
there you go balloon
okay I'm on here we go in my crunchy
spaghetti around in my neck all right
all right let's go to the balloon
in the bowl in the bowl in the bowl
okay
that's the big one
well done
that was hero
I feel fine and you gotta feel angrier
to all of you I know I'm very upset yeah
I'm also feeling weirdly gassy right now
yeah I feel like I really embodied a
spaghetti with them I'm also hungry for
spaghetti too yeah absolutely that's
happened absolutely spaghetti absolutely
yeah I don't feel rage I just feel like
the joy of teamwork
simultaneously gassy and hungry so I
don't know I think I'm confused but
that's gonna do it for the Cozy gaming
segment uh thank you everybody for
watching Everybody thanks for joining us
thank you guys all for playing with me
that was awesome stay with us uh grub
why don't you tell the people what we've
got going on here tomorrow yes tomorrow
we're gonna be back here at 10 A.M with
a voicemail dump truck it's our podcast
where people call and leave voicemails
10 a.m on this stage and then we have uh
after that it's gonna be uh the are you
smarter than a games journalist me and
my fellow games journalists which you're
allowed to boo when you hear that I'm
gonna say games girls boo games
journalists
[Music]
you're smarter than us it's gonna be a
trivia game you're gonna be able to
participate in that and then after that
it is a Super Mario Maker segment where
our buddy Davey has made a bunch of
challenging levels we're gonna run
through those it's gonna be a good time
so join us again tomorrow until then
have a good one everybody take care
everyone watching them suffer goodbye
thank you bye
[Music]
a life that you never thought you know
foreign
[Music]